why do you have to live with your
mother-in-law what you do wrong you're
like grown-up adults with a sixty
thousand dollar job and two kids and you
have no debt and forty two thousand
dollars in the bank you should not have
to live with your mother-in-law I ain't
living with my mother-in-law Haley with
no ending this is our fourth time so
yeah your fourth time living with her
the thing is his mom has said that he
would give us two acres oh that's sweet
I don't know if I'm living with my
mother-in-law
um two acres is not enough room
somehow being able to build like a
barndominium but I think your husband
needs to choose reality and the reality
is we can't afford the dream Barn
dominium we have to rent for a while
Mom's not the answer to your future
Prosperity you and your husband
developing a game plan is the answer to
your future Prosperity every time we run
home to her for future Prosperity your
life gets worse not better you pick up a
side job that you can do from home while
the kids are there you guys get to work
make some more money pile up some money
to add to the 42 and go get you a nice
little house that you can afford quit
running home to Mama you're too old